We need to move the orange dot
to the number equal to 5 by 1/3.
One way to think about it,
is that we need 5 times to move 1/3.
Let's do it once,
this will be 1/3,
we do it a second time, we get 2/3,
the third time and we get 3/3,
fourth time and we get 4/3,
fifth time and we get 5/3.
5 per 1/3 will be equal to 5/3.
Or you can say 5 per 1/3,
which is equal to 5/3,
I hope that makes sense.
Let's do a few other examples.
Let's say we have to find,
to see, we need to move the orange dot
of the number equal to 2 by 4/3.
Okay, once 4/3 will take us to 4/3,
once again 4/3,
we will add 4/3 to this,
we will move another 4/3 to the right.
4/3 plus 4/3 will give us 8/3.
8/3, it's hard to move it, 8/3.
1 in 4/3 is 4/3,
and 2 in 4/3 is 8/3.
Note that this is the same as 2 in 4,
which is 8, on 3, 8/3.
Let's do another example.
We have to move the orange dot to the number,
which is equal to 3 by 3/2.
This will be 0/2, it's just 0,
you can do this by 3/2.
1 by 3/2, this will take us to 3/2.
2 by 3/2, we add another 3/2,
and we get 6/2.
Then 3 by 3/2,
add another 3/2,
we get 9/2 and we're ready.